why do some world have rings and others
don't
why no rings for Earth or Mars we
wouldn't recognize Saturn without them
he looks naked without his rings but how
did he get them in the first place this
is exactly what the French astronomer
Edouard Roche asked himself when he
looked at Saturn through his telescope
in 1848 Roche speculated that Saturn's
rings were the debris of a moon or moons
that had ventured too close and were
pulled apart by the massive planet
[Music]
[Music]
Roche was able to devise an equation
that applies to all worlds it tells you
how closely a body can come to a planet
before it's pulled apart by the planets
tidal forces of gravity and is turned
into a ring
that's the Roche limit but until NASA's
Cassini spacecraft executed a series of
daredevil maneuvers in the Saturn system
there was a vigorous scientific debate
about when his rings formed some
astronomers suggested they were nearly
as old as the planet itself more than
four billion years ago when the planet
coalesced out of the disk of gas and
dust that surrounded the newborn Sun a
moon or moons
likely violated Saturn's Roche limit
others thought the Rings to be fairly
recent perhaps only a hundred million
years old or so and the Cassini
spacecraft proved them right what is
Earth's own Roche limit
if the moon were ever to come closer
than 12,000 miles which by the way it's
absolutely in no danger of doing
[Music]
and it's a good thing too because I like
our moon right where it is there's only
one other moon in the solar system that
moves me like ours does maybe it's
because it's the only one with a thick
atmosphere like Earth's and the kind of
surface features lakes and mountains
that remind me of home all of this was
hidden from view by a dense layer of
orange smog until the European Space
Agency collaborated with NASA to send a
spacecraft to land on his mysterious
surface yes that would be the one named
after you christiaan huygens first to
see that world through your telescope
[Music]
after an interplanetary voyage of seven
years
the Cassini Huygens spacecraft arrived
in the Saturn system the fourth of our
ships to venture there but the first to
send a probe to explore the surface of
Saturn's moon Titan
and to reveal a moon of far greater
complexity and splendor than our own
rather dull and lifeless moon
[Music]
as Carl Sagan had predicted more than
two decades before they were seas of
methane and FA and it was water ice when
Cassini first arrived in 2004 at
Saturn's northern hemisphere it was in
the depths of winter and the Sun didn't
come out until five years later when
Saturn's northern spring began is it
just me or is this whirling hexagon at
Saturn's North Pole every bit as exotic
as the fantasies our ancient ancestors
had of these worlds the geometrically
regular hexagonal shape of this feature
brings to mind the handiwork of
intelligence terraforming reworking the
surface for some unknown purpose but
it's actually the result of the sudden
change in wind speeds as vast upwellings
of ammonia could rise near the poles
it's the mother of all hurricanes a
frenzy of thunder and lightning
containing countless hurricanes was in
it
spring can be a violent stormy season on
earth too but it was during Saturn seven
year long summer that Cassini was
commanded to take her own life
[Music]
[Music]